often it's uh well i'm going to take the
easy route out but i'm going to justify
it by relating it to my career progress
it's like really guys that's pretty
pathetic you know seriously it's it's
pathetic and and i don't mean to be
morally judgmental i mean that it's
pathetic
in that what it will do is make you weak
and craven and probably you don't want
that you know like why would you want
that when you could be strong and
forthright instead like that's a way
better choice so don't
don't
say things that you don't believe and
especially don't write things that you
don't agree with
what would you say to people who would
say well don't inflame people don't draw
that's going to upset them well i would
say first of all you know that
you don't want to make unnecessary
enemies right there's nothing wrong with
prudence so you want to choose your
words carefully but you know part of
wisdom is knowing what to be afraid of
and
many times many many times in your life
perhaps with every important choice you
make your
you're you've got
terror on one side and terror on the
other there's no
way forward that doesn't involve risk
and
see there's a big problem with with
self-censorship
and that is that
every time you
fail to express who and what you are in
an articulated manner
you first of all lose an opportunity to
know yourself better and that's that's
not good because you have to pilot
yourself through life and life is a very
dangerous and treacherous
enterprise and if you don't know
yourself well then you won't pilot
yourself well and you will be hurt more
often than you need to be and that is
not trivial but the other thing is is
that you also weaken yourself and i'm
speaking as a clinical psychologist here
and i don't think there's any doubt
about this is that you know
your your mind is basically wired up
in many many different ways to determine
what constitutes a valid threat and
that's not an easy thing to figure out
like if you wake up in the morning and
your side is sore you know does that
mean you pull the muscle or does it mean
you have cancer it's like you don't know
you can't tell it's very difficult to to
to determine exactly how threatening a
threat is and one of the ways that your
brain figures that out is to watch you
and it assumes that if you if you
if you move away from something if you
if you retreat from something
it assumes that the thing that you're
retreating from is bigger than you and
that you're smaller than it
and so it makes you just that much more
existentially
weak and and frightened and so when you
have something to say and you don't say
it
then not only do you miss an opportunity
to articulate yourself properly which is
which is really fundamentally necessary
but you tell yourself right down to the
level of your soul that there's less of
you than there could be and that makes
the next retreat even more likely and so
you can easily initiate a positive
feedback loop where you retreat and you
get a little smaller and your enemy gets
a little bigger and then you retreat
again and you get a little smaller and
your enemy gets a little bigger and you
know you might be afraid to say what you
have to say and you might have every
reason to be afraid but you should even
be more afraid of not saying what you
have to say because the consequences of
that as they accrue over the long term
are they'll undermine everything for you
they'll undermine your faith in yourself
they'll undermine your family they'll
undermine your society that is not a
place you want to go
so yeah and we can take that to a very
personal level for you guys i mean when
when i do these events at colleges one
of the questions that i always get asked
and i i'm guessing we're going to
probably get asked in a few minutes is
well i have a professor who disagrees
with me or he's into all of this
post-modern stuff and i don't want to
speak my mind because it's going to
affect my grade and i used to say when a
couple years ago when i was doing this i
used to say to them well probably you
should just suck it up get the grade and
get out and i actually completely
disagree with that now because if you
guys now will silence yourselves it
doesn't suddenly magically get easier
when you're in the real world and you
have a job and a spouse and kids and all
these other worries so in a weird way it
kind of sucks for you now and you want
to get out you want to get a good grade
so you can get the good job and you can
have all the things that you want in
your life but i think you're totally
right that it will never get easier it
will just be a constant whittling away
at your ability to ever do it so if you
think it's not easy now it ain't gonna
get well and every time this is
something else you need to know and
there's a very solid literature on this
is that
you know one of the most ancient
one of the most ancient ideas that human
beings have had is that in some manner
our spirits speak being into existence
you know it's like the hallmark of
consciousness and it's one of the
reasons that individuals are valuable
and and it's a very deep idea and and
and a very necessary idea and i believe
one that's fundamentally true but it
carries with it certain more mortal
perils you might say
if you falsify your speech in the
service of a
proximal goal
you corrupt your soul
and or i could say more technically that
you damage your psyche
those are very similar ideas but the the
the evidence for that is crystal clear
you know because what happens to people
who say things they don't believe is
they come to believe the things they say
and the reason for that is
we talked a little earlier about the
fact that a lot of
you is unarticulated right and and so
there are things you know but you don't
know that you know them and you don't
know how to talk about them and so then
what you do is you decide that
to to reach a proximal goal like getting
a good grade well you have to say what
the professor wants so you write out an
essay you know there's no soul in it and
you feel sick while you're writing it
and you're not interested in it and you
feel small which are always all hints
from your being that you shouldn't be
doing that but you do it anyways and
then at the end you've got two choices
like you're either a liar and a coward
or you believe what you wrote
and there's plenty of psychological
evidence for this and what people do is
decide that they believe what they wrote
because it's less painful than noting
that you're a liar and a coward and not
only that you've articulated a counter
argument
and so
your original conviction remains
unarticulated and the counter argument
is articulated so you've built yourself
your own enemy
and you will pay for that you pay for
that with a diminishment of your
character and your character is what
sustains you through life there isn't
you don't have in any in any fundamental
sense you don't have anything else
because that's the thing that enables
you to master the continual onslaught of
chaos and uncertainty that will that you
will be faced with for your entire life
you do not
pollute your character
you pay for it and so does everyone else
and if if it goes far enough then
everyone else pays horribly for it
that's the lesson of the 20th century
so
don't do that and if you do that at
university it's like a it's like a
mortal sin
it's it runs absolutely contrary to the
spirit of the institution it is
precisely the opposite to
it's the absolute polar opposite to why
you're here
do not do it and it's also a kind of
it's a kind of
second-rate cynicism because even though
there is a fair bit of rot in the
academic institutions
most of the time if you write an
articulate essay that the professor
doesn't agree with you will not be
punished with a failing grade it's very
rare that that actually happens now
there is the odd professor who's so damn
corrupt that that's going to be the case
but i've talked to lots of students and
counseled them to write down what they
think and their grade generally
surprises them quite spectacularly
because they're invested in the damn
essay and so they do the work right and
they put a little passion into it and
and they're not bored by it or made sick
by what they're producing and then they
end up with a grade that's far better
than they think so you know often it's
uh well i'm going to take the easy route
out but i'm going to justify it by
relating it to my career progress it's
like really guys that's pretty pathetic
you know seriously it's it's pathetic
and and i don't mean to be morally
judgmental i mean that it's pathetic
in that what it will do is make you weak
and craven and probably you don't want
that you know like why would you want
that when you could be strong and
forthright instead
like that's a way better choice so don't
don't
say things that you don't believe and
especially don't write things that you
don't agree with
you you
you it's a bad idea it's it's a terrible
idea so don't do that ever ever
it goes back to the issue that you were
bringing up which i definitely agree
with that speech and thought go together
and the totalitarians knew this this is
why in soviet russia they would parade
everybody into meetings where you had to
espouse the dogma most people didn't
believe it but the totalitarians knew
that it does something internally to the
person to make them speak things they
don't agree with
over and over and over it's very very
corrupting um and to do that to yourself
when you're not being forced to do it
it's crazy
so then what do we do about the the
truly bad ideas so when these white
supremacists are out there marching
basically saying that by the color of
their skin
that that somehow gives them
more um
either more importance or more ownership
of this country i mean it's contrary of
course to the constitution into basic
decency and all that what do we do now i
don't want these people silenced and i
don't i had to defend uh richard spencer
when he got punched i don't i don't want
you know i hate the fact that we use
nazi now all the time but i don't want
these people to be punched for their
ideas you actually make them the victims
which is really what they want they want
to claim victimhood um so what do we do
though about the ideas that are truly
terrible and truly dangerous that's uh
that's a great question so i guess there
are two things one is we have to have
better ideas and confidence in our good
ideas and i think that's part of what's
going on here is that
um is that i mean you know
the the the
all of the what i would say the best
ideas in history in western civilization
are under attack right now the idea of
reason the idea of individualism
um you know i think the free market uh
and freedom in general people don't
understand what individual rights um the
rule of law looks like and when you get
to a point where especially
people are actually attacking reason
free will or ability to think it disarms
people and they and they have every
reason then if if you haven't taught
them to think throughout their lives
they have reason to fear bad ideas
because they don't understand how bad
ideas function but let me make one more
sort of practical point which has to do
with the intersection of of law and our
understanding of individual rights um
take charlottesville there's a there's
there's a lot of really bad
ideas woven into
our our
laws today and the first amendment is no
exception now i'm about as fun as free
speech absolutist as you can find but i
think there's something very wrong with
the idea and
this has been a mistake that the supreme
court has made for a long time very
wrong with the idea that number one that
we don't make a distinction between
speech and action we have to make a
distinction in the law between speech
and action and number two there can't be
a right to march on public property the
way the white supremacists did in
charlottesville it makes no sense it's
not that i'm that i'm against you know
uh people marching for their ideas they
have to do it i think if you're gonna
have public parks and public streets and
and all the like which we obviously have
we it's just not fundamentally possible
to say
people like white supremacists or
anybody have a right to clog the streets
have a right to march in public parks
think about how the people in
charlottesville felt and what they were
confronted with i mean the people who
live there one day a bunch of white
supremacists and nazis show up literally
carrying torches in their uh in their
you know public parks and then you get a
rival gang showing up and they basically
have a gang war right and the police are
confronted with this idea that somehow
this is free speech that we have to
tolerate this as an example of free
speech it's not free speech i think the
yeah well no is that contrary though to
skokie vs illinois where it is yeah so
so i think that's why i started by
saying i think the supreme court has
made a mistake now it's an
understandable mistake but i think it
was it was the wrong decision to say
that you have a literal right to march
on public property it's just not it's
not a right that can be made consistent
with the rights of other people you have
a you're building an inherent conflict
into the law and once people come to see
the right to free speech as nazis
literally have a right to come to my
town clog the streets up and and what
they were doing what the white
supremacists were doing and antifa both
which i regard basically as morally
equivalent but they're not they're not
in in that circumstance they they didn't
do all the exact same things but i mean
imagine what that means a band of people
with helmets on with shields with sticks
and actually carrying torches that's not
an effort to communicate to people
that's an effort to intimidate people
that's i think what the nazis were doing
in skokie was that was an effort to
intimidate
the people of skokie illinois and i i
think it's a mistake that the supreme
court allowed them to do it now that's
not because they were nazis it's because
they were engaging in a kind of
intimidation we can't conflate speech
and action those two things have to be
separated what's the what's the action
the march on public streets
that's and and and now you know one look
the the the best thing would be if they
want to have a march on private property
that's all up to them and everybody can
say screw you we're gonna stay away i
don't wanna i don't wanna do it but
think of what happens when there's a
march on public property it's a it
amounts to
my tax dollars as a person in in skokie
let's say illinois or in charlottesville
i have to now pay for these [ __ ] to
come and intimidate people in my town
that's crazy why should i be forced as a
taxpayer to pay for these guys to have a
march that is designed to intimidate
people they are coming ready for a gang
war and for some strange reason
taxpayers are supposed to pay for that i
and so let me just it's interesting
you're making the equivalence though
with with antifa because again six
hundred thousand dollars yeah it's the
same out of the berkeley if you if you
treat that as free speech if if people
come to view free speech as someone has
a right to invade my space and at my
expense have a gang war on my property
i'd be against free speech as well so
the only solution in that is you have to
separate those two issues gotta separate
um two two issues speech and action have
to be made separate we can't treat all
action as speech action is necessary for
speech speech is a type of action but it
can't be that i have a right to
intimidate other people it's just and
and that's that's definitely true in the
law and and so you don't have a right to
incite violence you don't have to write
a right to threaten people but it's it's
it's i think far too narrowly construed
what constitutes a threat and i think
the white supremacists marching in
charlottesville was a threat it was
intended as a threat antifa coming in
was also a threat it was basically a
gang war at public expense that's insane
people are not going to support free
speech if they see it
under those terms and then finally to
the extent we have public spaces and
public parks and the like it can't be
that anybody has a right to do anything
on that on that property that they want
it's it's not true now in in many ways
but it shouldn't be that we we hold that
that every public space is
open to any kind of speech it just can't
be it's not it's not actually feasible
this is why when you when you hold that
that you have a right to essentially
confront others on public property you
necessarily build a clash into your laws
and and it's it becomes irresolvable
well people see it as irresolvable and
their own and i think the logical
response is to say well then let's
jettison free speech so no no public
square um no i think you could have
public squares but they have to be um
very highly regulated it's an
unfortunate fact i'm not a fan of of
saying this right this is the guy who
doesn't like regulation
yeah a little surprised
well we've done something very backwards
here i know so um but but i'm not saying
the libertarians are getting pissed i
know the libertarians will definitely
get pissed at me and a lot of people
will but uh but that's fine i'm a fan of
being uh having people pissed at me or i
don't mind it um but my point is not is
not that i want to restrict free speech
it's that you just can't have
public property a public square where
anybody gets to to go in there and have
um what essentially amounts to a melee
or or
or a
a march that is intended to intimidate
people that's what the white
supremacists were in charlottesville to
do i mean you can tell by everything
they did carry torches for god's sakes
it's like they were going after the
monster and the you know they they
surrounded the statue that's all
intimidation tax if you're going to have
public squares and i mean we have them
right so they are they're a fact i'm not
arguing against the existence of uh i
mean i you know in a perfect world yeah
we can get rid of them but we have the
world in which in which they exist so
all i'm saying is given that we have
public property it has to be managed by
the government there's just no choice
it's not i'm not a fan of having the
government manage these things but the
way the supreme court i think has
interpreted the first amendment to allow
this sort of free fall for all or to
interpret a march as the same thing as
us communicating up here it doesn't make
any sense it's i think it's just sort of
metaphysically wrong it's it's it's a
real mistake in
the way they view free speech i mean
just as if i stand up now and i threaten
to punch you that's not free speech but
it is communicating something and if if
we allow people to get away with that
then they will come to associate speech
and force and they will jettison speech
and that's actually what's happening on
college campuses i think a lot of
students feel threatened they think god
how do i get away from this stuff
imagine being in charlottesville and
thinking i don't want white supremacists
on my in my you know in my town how do i
get away with from this the supreme
court has said i have to put up with it
and what's the logical conclusion from
that well then screw free speech and my
answer is you don't have to put up with
it do this by applause so that the the
people that are watching online can hear
you how many of you have since you've
been at school here and i assume most of
you guys are students how many of you
have not said something either in a
class or to a friend or to a professor
because of you feared the repercussions
yeah
i know it doesn't quite feel right to
applaud that but yeah that's uh but that
says it right there you know it's funny
i get only invited by conservatives and
libertarians and uh you know some
classical liberal groups i always say
i'll give the same speech to
progressives or liberals if you know
them whatever you want to call them
democrats lefties whatever if they'll
invite me they never do but i find all
the time i come and i talk to you guys
and it's like wow there
i look i can look out here there's a lot
of diversity out here the diversity that
the left loves i see a lot of different
skin colors here i'm sure there's some
different sexualities here and all sorts
of stuff but that doesn't matter what i
know matters and what you know matters
is diversity of thought
how did we lose
that
that
caring for diversity of thought on
campus well i
diagnosed this as the free speech
problem is very serious
it is uh
as as steve says you either have
discourse or you have force
and discourse is what human beings
developed over millennia
as an alternative to brute force to get
their way and it is a thing of beauty
and the pinnacle of civilizational
accomplishment so the
the current attacks on free speech are
extremely
dangerous for our civilization but i
think the free speech problem is just an
epiphenomenon of even more serious
problem
which is the
incessant cultivation
of a victim identity on the part of an
ever-growing
group of students
and this is now the obsessive
goal of education starting in grammar
school even where you have fifth graders
being
indoctrinated into the whole
complex
mythology of white privilege
and it continues in in high school and
certainly in college
uh there's now huge
bureaucracies that here at berkeley you
have a 20 million dollar vice chancellor
of equity diversity inclusion
whose purpose
is to continue hammering home the
preposterous point
that to be a female or person of color
on the berkeley campus is to be under
literal existential threat
and as long as that remains the dominant
belief
that
to be
in this ever growing number of victim
groups
is to be a literal threat for your life
you there used to have a banner on
campus of two students of color saying
allow people other than yourself to
exist
that's modeling language but it's meant
literally
as long as that remains the dominant
thinking
it will follow
that
non-conforming
non-orthodox speech
is viewed
not just as hate speech
again ridiculously but that hate speech
is a literal threat to one's existence
and i think
we're not going to solve the free speech
problem we can have faculty signing all
the petitions they want you know if only
moore did so in favor of free speech
it's not going to matter as long as this
victimology ideology remains the
dominant one in higher education well
steve as a straight white man would you
like to apologize to the audience yeah
middle-aged straight white man i mean is
there anything worse
straight white man with all women in my
family so i'm apologizing every damn day
that's a constant apology
all right how do we how do we reverse
some of this i mean we talked about this
over dinner and we all sort of were like
wow are we
i i like to think that i'm an optimist
at heart uh heather you said you're a
pessimist
constitutionally yes where do you
consider yourself
i'm torn between you guys i was i was on
your side at first and now now i'm i'm
i'm generally an optimist but i have but
i'm i'm an optimist that's realistic
about i'm optimistic because of the
potential of human beings i'm optimistic
because we can think we can achieve
things look at the society we live in
today i mean this is one of so one of
the great the big rebuttals too or one
of the things that people just ignore in
the whole victimology i just look at the
society we live in my god it's the most
advanced freest greatest society in the
history of the world that i mean there's
something to be taken from that not just
that they're wrong to constantly be
playing victims and claim that they're
oppressed in a context in which they're
not oppressed but that human beings can
achieve unbelievable things that's a
great thing so i'm optimistic there
human beings can also ruin great things
and i'm concerned about the future
because of the direction of this issue
and i think a lot of what heather said i
i think there are deeper issues going on
which i don't want to we can talk about
them but i agree with the victimology
point i think that's a consequence of
even deeper philosophical convictions
and and convictions about ideas that are
leading us to be victims to reject
rationality and speech um to reject
individualism to cloy onto groups and
and the the the rise of tribalism all of
these things are playing a role in that
but you're absolutely right that this
prosperity that has been achieved
through
freedom through trade through free
markets is stunning i mean every every
item in this room has been created by
some guy who's got a company or some
woman
in the in the market chain it's
extraordinary but that doesn't persuade
people and if they can if a student on a
campus like this which is so beautiful i
was in the main library today with these
grand reading rooms and the noble
architecture and the
the
plants the trees you've got around if
they can feel sorry for themselves and
feel oppressed
at berkeley
i mean that's preposterous they are
leading
they are living
a charmed life they're leading a
delusion they are they are completely
unable to perceive their privilege to be
at a place of learning where they should
be down on their knees every day saying
thank you
for giving me this opportunity to absorb
human history languages science you name
it well that's why i think it's so
fascinating because there's such a
disconnect between the reality of of the
goodness of this country not to say we
don't have problems and and what this
sort of post-modern cultural marxist
collectivist set of ideas whatever you
want to call it is about i mean you know
i say this on the show all the time but
the essence of prejudice is to pre-judge
i could look at you guys right now and
go okay brown guy here white guy here
girl here brown guy there asian guy
there white lady there and that would
assuming that i thought that that meant
i know what you think that actually is
prejudice and yet somehow
we're the ones that are constantly being
told that we're bigots and racists i
assume most of you guys again will do it
by applause i know it's weird to
applause these things but most of you i
assume have been called all of these
these things and yeah
i need to figure out
i need to figure out some other way to
gauge reaction other than applauding all
the bad things we know this is the way
this thing will be clipped on youtube
reuben did a live stream they were
applauding bigotry and racism
oh lord we stepped in it people um
somehow the raising of the hand does you
know a hand signal that won't go well
either so uh
jazz hands all right we'll do jazz hands
for now on i see people we have a gay
guy you see
you see
gay people but i don't judge him it's
okay it's okay people
the people that lived in skokie as you
said the second largest amount of
holocaust survivors in the country
these people literally survived a
genocide probably virtually all of them
lost some of them probably lost all of
their family members and friends and all
of that
and yet i would sit here as someone that
lost holocaust survivors on both sides
of my family and tell you it was the
right decision you can't let the the
nazis or the white supremacists or
whatever they are you can't let them
start ransacking property you can't let
them start killing people or harming
people
but letting letting them march that's
the exchange of free speech and it's
kind of shitty but you got to defend it
when it's hard to defend well you have
to defend it when it's hard to defend
because otherwise there's it's not going
to be around to defend when it's easy to
defend you know once you start creating
exceptions and encroaching there's no
end to it and you know we've kind of
seen even in other countries uh
that once the encroachments start
it's always well we make that exception
and just this one other small exception
and then there's inevitably another one
and another one and all for perhaps even
you know
good reasons in terms of you know ideals
and the goals are are laudable perhaps i
say in every show the road to hell is
paved with good intentions i'm getting
tired of saying
you and me both yeah uh but you know
it's really practically speaking it's
inevitable yeah
how much of this is just a confusion as
to what the first amendment is that's
also what i've started to realize
because when i've gone on college
campuses and the protesters are there
and i always say it i welcome
peaceful protests i completely welcome i
welcome the exchange of ideas the
questions all of that but when when
they're screaming about certain things i
think there's just a disconnect as to
what i think two legal things i think
what the first amendment is and what
hate speech is is or isn't uh so can you
talk about that a little bit yeah i i if
i had to have to hear one more person
whether it be student uh internet
commenter even journalists or faculty
members sometimes say hate speech is not
free speech i'm going to lose it okay so
let's do let's do that one first because
i really i mean this will be maybe what
we promote for this episode but i really
want people to understand this why is
hate speech free speech
well on a legal level hate speech is
free speech because uh the first
amendment and the courts have said
nothing about free or hate speech being
unprotected by the first amendment
speech is protected by the first
amendment unless it falls under one of
the very few existing categories of
unprotected speech yeah what are those
categories uh there's incitement to
imminent lawless action
um these all have very high bars right
true threats and intimidation
uh you can be sued for uh bible or
slander defamation as they're known some
states i think actually still have
criminal statutes on the book books but
they're rarely enforced
fraud
obscenity which people often confuse
with mere profanity or lewdness but they
are not the same thing by any stretch of
the imagination what's the difference on
those two well profanity and lewdness
are generally protected by the first
amendment obscenity is a very
high bar it's speech that has to be or
expression i should say more broadly
than just speech
that has to appeal to the prurient
interest which is an inordinate
fascination with sex
describe or depict sex in a patently
offensive way
and have no social
political literary or artistic value
whatsoever and
to
get down in the in the mud
have you ever heard of crush videos
i feel like i have but i'm honestly not
sure what that is they are videos of
women wearing stilettos crushing small
animals like hamsters and gerbils to
death and people apparently get off on
that
i don't pretend to understand it
even that is not wholly unprotected
by the obscenity exception to the first
amendment that that's a particularly
interesting case i suppose because the
idea of it talking about it seems like
uh i would have no problem with that but
the action itself probably there's some
legal reasons right like killing killing
animals there's some law i guess of
charlie state law right but if you have
this uh pornography you can call it that
i just i have a hard time getting it
yeah um
if you have it and you
to possess it
you can't be prosecuted for for
possessing that obscene material it's an
interesting distinction that the act is
the crime
or the act is what is illegal not the
depiction depiction or the disseminating
of the information or that sort of thing
right child pornography obviously not
protected by the first amendment yeah uh
you know but
there's well there's the one additional
wrinkle of the fighting words doctrine
although there's a
considerable doubt that it remains a
viable
exception to the first amendment
but it really
gets brought up a lot in the hate speech
debate
to the extent it still exists it's
limited to face-to-face interactions
where say i say something to you that is
so insanely abusive that you are likely
to punch me in the face without thinking
twice about it instead of taking a deep
breath and either ignoring me or coming
back at me and there's reasons why it's
fallen into disuse and it's worthwhile
to note that the supreme court hasn't
upheld a fighting words conviction since
the case in the forties when it created
the fighting words except that's
interesting which is how far it's fallen
into disuse
it incentivizes
punching people in the face right it
creates an easy way to censor the people
that you disagree with and it would i
assume be some level of a subjective
piece of information as to what you
think is offensive at the highest order
is different perhaps than what i think
or exactly what some of these other
people yeah it creates terrible
incentives and it would basically lead
to an institutionalized hecklers veto uh
so it's really not tenable yeah so on
the on the hate speech front which it's
clear what the supreme court has said
about hate speech you're allowed to do
it with with these exceptions that
you've just laid out you're allowed to
say mean things what i what i'm
realizing on college campuses is they
really don't like that the people the
set of people that we're talking about
they really don't like that so like they
think if you like you it's just a fact
you are allowed to say bad things you
can say i hate all the jews you can say
i hate all the black people or all the
gays or whatever you can say it you
can't cause direct call to violence but
what i think they think
is that if you keep saying those things
i hate these people that it's going to
incite violence now my counterargument
would be no you have to use free speech
to counter those bad ideas that's the
whole purpose of free speech but do you
see that that that seems to be the slope
that they consistently are on that if we
allow you to say i i hate these people
which is bigoted and prejudice and all
those things but it's afforded to us
by the bill of rights they think that
that's going to get you to violence how
do you combat that notion if you agree
with the premise well you know that is
something that we tend to hear a lot in
the first amendment world
and
you know first of all
generally speaking in this country we
punish the people who do the bad acts if
i watch your show and i get some kooky
idea and go off and you know commit some
crime we're not going to throw you in
jail because i'm an idiot and took a
terrible idea that you didn't even
intend me to take right now it might be
it might be different though if i was up
here saying you should violently attack
these people et cetera right exactly and
that's why the incitement standard is so
high yes to be
likely to incite and intended to incite
immediate criminal action
so if i tell you hey you know it'd be
fun to burn down a building but you're
not likely to do it
you're going to take it as a joke
i probably haven't you know committed
any kind of you know unlawful expression
if i know you're a pyromaniac and i say
hey dave let's go burn down a building
right i might you know find myself in a
very different situation i sort of left
that phase at about eight years old but
but
you know i think that
if you take a look one of my colleagues
actually wrote a piece for quillette uh
not so long ago about the rwandan
genocide
and looking over the claims that the
radio broadcasts actually
you know caused more violence and what
it turns out
is that the radio broadcasts first of
all
only
incited
people who
were already predisposed and who already
felt that way and it made it marginally
easier for them to find people and you
know
be taught how to do certain things
but
it was relatively ineffective
as it turns out in convincing people who
weren't already
in a murderous rage to go out and commit
violence uh and so you know i think that
the
fear that allowing these views to be
aired is going to
indisputably cause actual violence
is
somewhat overblown
now there's a second part to it which is
that
people expressing these views
might lead to more people adopting those
views and having prejudiced views
is that possible
absolutely right so that's the part i
was referencing but that's kind of the
point is that we put those views out
there so we can fight them
if we
don't have them in public and we can't
fight them they're still going to spread
nothing no idea ever went away because
we said you can't say that but the free
speech on college campus since we're on
a college campus i thought that would be
the right way to start i i view this
basically as the single most important
issue of the day i mean i've been
bouncing around college campuses now for
the last year and the i think the number
one question that i get from you guys is
that you are afraid often to speak
not only within your your peer group
because you don't want people to call
you a bigot or a racist because you may
believe in small government or low taxes
or something like that but that with
your own professors you're afraid to
challenge them because of what the
blowback might be to any of you just
quickly by showing hands or applause do
any of you have that fear here i'm
wondering how much yeah so that's wow
that's about half of you right there so
that's that's kind of interesting to me
that that on college campuses i mean
this is the place this is the place
where not only are you supposed to learn
history you're supposed to learn how to
think and how to critically think and
all that but you're also supposed to be
challenged and you're supposed to
challenge people too and i find it so
amazing consistently that so many
professors these days apparently seem to
be afraid to be challenged when
that's exactly what they should be
trying to do with you guys uh you are a
teacher
what do you make of this phenomena i
think it's really sad it's like you said
as
as a college instructor
it's not
it's not telling students
what to think it's it's it's teaching
them how to think
you know and
there's this big controversy about
safe spaces these days and things that
you shouldn't talk about because you're
going to trigger students and
i think that the entire university
campus
is a place you know it shouldn't be a
safe space
you know this is the place to
[Music]
criticize and to argue and to question
and that's the only way that we can
learn it's the only way we can expand
our minds i mean i grew up
being told that
questioning something
is the devil whispering in my ear
that if i don't just do what i'm told
and
and
accept what i'm being taught
then that's evil
right
and so when i
what's happening these days is is really
well it's triggering to me
you know so one of the things we talked
about this afternoon was that you are
shocked that someone that has lived
through what what totalitarianism and
what authoritarianism actually does what
you live through it and what clothes you
could wear and what thoughts you could
have in what in what people you could be
friends with et cetera et cetera you're
you're sort of uh
i don't want to say depressed but you
find the
the fact that so many of these people on
college campus are so against so many of
these freedoms now you find it shocking
is that is that even the right adjective
yeah yeah it's
it's yeah it is it's depressing because
i feel like what is the end goal like
what are you what are you aiming for
when you hear people talking about
shutting down speech and burning books
it's like what
what are you looking for are you looking
for sharia law like what is
where is this going to lead
but i don't think that they think that
far ahead they're just
you know i don't know i don't know
so it seems to me that i i try not to
impugn people's motives it's one of the
things i talk about on the show a lot i
don't want i don't believe that all the
people of the left are evil i think that
that the ideology is bad i think the
leaders
often are bad or corrupt or have ideas
that i think are wrong but i don't think
that the average person or the average
student that's on a college campus that
has those ideas is evil
what's the best way do you think to
counter some of those ideas or wake up
people who may not be evil but are just
mistaken
um
yeah i mean i think a lot of it is it's
a product of the education that you're
receiving and it's very one-sided and
particularly in the humanities so all
the sciences history economics that deal
with man
if you look at the history of the 20th
century the it's
dominated by
marxist socialists
um
and i mean now they'll be put as the
progressives that were in the late 19th
early 20th century and it's one line of
thought
it does not anywhere come close to all
the views you should be thinking about
entertaining discussing arguing about i
mean part of the reason i went into
philosophy i was already interested in
iran and objectivism but the idea that
that's all i would read and that's all i
would hear i went to a university where
it had a lot of different viewpoints in
philosophy and i want to hear all the
theories all the viewpoints and there's
very little of that now that happens in
colleges and it's it's a crime against
you guys it's a crime against students
to do this to students i would never
just teach objectivism even though i
think it's right to students and no
don't hear about plato don't hear about
mark i mean are we remarks in my classes
i don't think he's right about anything
basically but you have to know some of
the arguments and if you're going to
have a view of your own you have to be
able to counter the other arguments and
if you never hear them and if it's
somehow taboo and you're going to shout
them down as they're racists or bigots
just because they disagree
there's something really has gone wrong
with education and it's that's what i
think has to be turned and it has to
come apart from the students demand like
we want something better than what we're
getting in the classroom yeah it's also
interesting to me how so many words have
flipped the meaning i mean if i was to
look at you guys and i can see people
that are white and i can see people that
are brown and i can see girls and guys
and people of different ages and all
that and if we were to look at you only
based in those
ideas that actually as i always say this
is prejudice that is prejudging i don't
expect because i look at you that i know
what any of your political thoughts are
or ideas are and yet we're sold this
idea of diversity constantly as if this
is how we should be looking at each
other that oh here we have black people
here they should think a certain way
muslim people should think a certain way
white people should think a certain way
whatever it is this is actually it's the
antithesis of the american project it's
completely the reverse of martin luther
king jr's most famous phrase about his
children being judged by the content of
their character not the color of their
skin and yet somehow this is like
actually caught fire with a certain set
of people
yeah identity politics is uh is racism
basically it's the true racism
yeah it's unfortunate and it's really
insulting too because people
ian herciali when she did her interview
with you actually was talking about how
people look at her and she's a black
woman immigrant and
the progressives will look at her
and assume right away that she's a
victim and that she is being oppressed
by this horrible american society etc
etc and of course she is not
she is an amazing woman she's a survivor
you know she's
she doesn't want those kinds of
she doesn't want anybody's pity
so she gets to define who she is other
people don't get to define it for her
but people are just looking at diversity
of identity versus diversity of of
opinion or diversity of thought agar how
how do you think victimhood got so sexy
to people the idea that victimhood is
virtue or the idea that because you were
born a certain color or a certain
sexuality or
whatever that's outside of the
mainstream that somehow that gives you
extra authority
i mean i think that's a philosophical
viewpoint and it a lot of it comes from
religion that religion plays up
victimhood and if you just think in
christianity think of
jesus in the sermon in the mount
it's the meek
and the poor and not in the poor
material
the poor in spirit i mean we would call
it now now losers
that's who's going to inherit the earth
it's and that sets it up that the
if you don't have something if you don't
have intelligence if you don't have
wealth if you don't have a real soul
you're poor in spirit that's what gives
you claims to things or claims against
whom the people who've made something of
their spirit the people who are strong
in various kinds of ways intelligence
and so on and there's a real packaging
of the victimhood is you can think of
victims in two kinds of ways you're a
victim of injustice
or you're a victim just because
you are in need or you're suffering and
so on and those are two very different
things and religion packaged those
together so there's a tendency to think
if someone's a victim they must have
suffered an injustice
that's not true you can be a loser yeah
and you deserve to be at the bottom
because you are you're not a nice person
you're not honest you're not just and so
you're at the bottom it should be at the
bottom you're a criminal and you're in
prison and that's not like but to
elevate that the mere fact that you're
losing as that is indicates something is
wrong that's not true but religion
really pushed that idea and then it
became secularized i mean marxism is
from each according to his need
from their people's ability that's it
elevated need and the victim into that's
what counts and it trumps everything if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about free
speech instead of non-stop yelling check
out our free speech playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell